[Musique]
c'est l'été il fait chaud très chaud
pourquoi ne pas se rafraîchir avec une
bonne crème glacée et pourquoi pas d'une
glace végétalienne les glaces
végétalienne sont offerts un peu partout
que ce soit la crémerie du coin ou
encore en épicerie en compagnie des
script aux nutritionnistes ont déballé
glacières de produits végétalien de
toutes sortes
c'est un marché en pleine croissance
quand on voit des grandes marques très
établis comme ben jerry's comme häagen
dazs ou même les marques privées c'est
signe que c'est pas juste une tendance
de passage mais qui a clairement un
potentiel de marché est donc clairement
un intérêt des consommateurs des
produits qui suivent la tendance des
laits végétaux et qui une fois gelée se
transforme en dessert glacé
la loi demande d discuté ces produits
comme des desserts glacés et non pas
quand même crème glacée d'abord et avant
tout parce que ça contient pas créé mon
anglais mais en réalité c'est
véritablement à le défaire
certaines compagnies aurensan un peu
magique en faisant que c'est vegan
d'ondés santé ou mais non c'est parce
que puis vivienne que c'est plus lente
et oui ça le soit un avantage mais c'est
a reçu un défi glacé
ce qu'on remarque c'est ceux qui sont
faits à base de boissons de soya sont
souvent plus faibles en gras mais
beaucoup plus riches en sucre à
l'inversé se faire à tire d'ailés coucou
là on est vraiment riche en gras même en
gras saturés du hockey beaucoup mais sur
un peu plus fervents sucre donc par être
le ferment plus tenté par ce que c'est
big n
on trouve des produits au parfum de
toutes sortes comme chocolat photo jh
caramel salé beurre d'arachide les
nouveaux produits en rond dans une
mi-temps gens très très gourmand il est
aussi gourmande en fait que leur
penchard est à base de lait donc kippot
de vote compromis du tout du tout sur la
gâterie en particulier qui ont retenu
mon attention qui le chocolat fondant
salé et truffes de häagen dazs concile
12 gamme de matelas grâce et 30 grammes
de sucre par les deux mi temps ce yacht
quoi ce soit de vous envoyer faire un
bon jogging ou une bonne sieste
ça c'est très très décapante tout comme
une langue base régulière
c'est préférable mais c'est très bon au
goût parfois ses desserts glacés ne
contiennent aucune boisson végétale
elles sont uniquement faite à base d'eau
de sucre et d'huile les glaces crêpes à
partir de bois sont des droits
fondamentaux
on les avait un peu étrange au sirop de
riz brun siro bagages marteau des
strings de vie biologique ville de
tournesol l'huile de carthame pour moi
s'il y avait quoi sont inférieures ou
boissons les cocos en premier je trouve
c'est plus logique comme les ingrédients
que tous les agréments jaloux mise comme
dans la crème glacée les quantités de
gras et de sucre sont importantes et il
est facile d'en consommer plus que la
portion de référence les menaces qui
peut donc aisément que la plupart des
gens vont manger plus succulents d'une
passe ici on a souvent juste au sens de
la vie quotidienne pour le gras saturés
pour une demi tasse dans si je mettais
mon produit à une tasse des jalouses je
réfléchirai quoi 140% j'ai sûrement une
base de leurs produits lactés comme ça
pour le consommateur c'est important de
toujours vérifier par rapport à la
portion que lui main
donc c'est la portion de référence si
moi je veux bien mais c'est juste un
gramme dessus mais je mange trois fois
faire il est préférable de choisir des
produits le moins transformés oui eh bé
produit quand même qui fore ressorti
comme étant des meilleurs choix que
d'autres notamment en raison lors les
ingrédients qui est plus courte qui
retombe que ça quelque chose que je
préfère la maison un produit de luxe
vendus en petit format mais qui coûte
quatre fois plus cher qu'une crème
glacée classique si on choisit ce type
de produit l'homme que pour des raisons
environnementales
mieux vous repensez à notre affaire
parce que le seuil à la noix de coco et
la bande son des cultures intensives qui
affecte significativement
l'environnement si on veut faire une
différence et mieux vous se retourner
vers produits sans ogm
idéalement biologique ou bien vers une
crème glacée traditionnelle fête au
québec
avec notre lait chez nous
l'impact environnemental ne sera pas
pire que pour les médias culture qu'on
retrouve du côté végétalisme celle de
trouver un produit parfait de deux
bâtons quand même sacrément et c'est
pour le plaisir
l'idée de choisir quoi dit qu'on est mou
évidemment c'est peut-être une scpi
quand même
[Musique]